[Music]
I'm going to talk about a question
really that puzzles all of us and
there's so much going on in the universe
that what scientists do of course is to
look for systematic ways of accounting
for what is observed so they would
formulate their so-called laws of nature
and as far as I'm concerned a law of
nature is a summary of of observations
so you make a series of observations and
then you summarize them by a so called
law of nature
some of which are mathematical and some
of which are more verbal the question
really arises is where do they come from
who imposed laws on this universe that
gives us a kind of a structure for
understanding everything that is going
on there as you would suspect
theologians the bane of my life like the
bane of most people's lives have sort of
thought that they might be imposed upon
us rather like they would rather like
moral law so that we would get kind of
the Ten Commandments but in fact the
laws of nature and an acquaintance of
mine philosopher so I have to regard him
with some suspicion and I wouldn't go
quite as far as saying a friend but more
of a friend and more of a friend in the
in in the Facebook sense I suppose
it came up with what he thought was the
simplest possible account for the
existence of systemic behavior in the
world he's a grown man but you would not
suspect it from what he thinks he
thought he claims that the simplest
possible approach is that God is
everywhere and pushes every electron in
the right direction every moment and
does so for the whole of eternity if you
like for every electron every proton
every Neutron and everything that man
might in due course invent now I don't
think that's very plausible being rather
profligate and my view is that
scientists use of simplicity out of
complexity that they they look at this
extraordinarily beautiful world and see
it as a forest of events that has
emerged from simple acorns okay so they
are looking for the simple
infrastructure of the world things that
I've partly represented by by that so we
scientists are looking for simple
explanations and not for sort of
heavy-handed intrusion into the workings
of the world so I wondered and what I
want to try to convince you this
afternoon
is whether there are three principles
that might be adequate for accounting
for all the laws of nature and the three
principles are indolence doing nothing
okay
and if indolence is too exhausting for
you then allow Anarchy to play a role
and if anarchy really is too troublesome
to cope with then invoke ignorance so I
think and I'm going to try to convince
you that those of nature actually emerge
from a combination of indolence anarchy
and ignorance and let me see if I can do
that I'm going to talk about the
universe and I'm not much of a historian
so this is the history of the universe
as far as I'm concerned
starting from absolutely nothing and I'm
going to come back to tell you a lot
about absolutely nothing later on and
many people think that once you've got a
some sort of laws of nature once you've
got a universe then it can give rise to
daughter universes and so on and that
our universe might be one of these
daughter universes so they think that
the properties of the universe might
emerge because you've got a universe
which simply spawns another universe I
think that's solving the problem I want
to think about the original universe
this particular universe and which might
be our universe it's no no one knows
whether we are a daughter universe or a
grandmother universe so but surely and
when I say surely I'm insecure in saying
that there must have been a moment back
a long long time ago when the universe
emerged from nothing that is when
something when nothing converted itself
into what seems to be something so I
want to focus on that point of the
inception of the universe
no I mean there are arguments against
this it might be that time is circular
it's very hard to see how that might be
we've only experienced time for a short
period of human existence and it could
be that in the scale of trillions of
years and then time goes round in a
circle just like you know space in a
certain sense goes around in a circle
but let's discount that and suppose that
there really was a beginning of of time
and really that is the nothing that
preceded what appears to be something
and I think that absolutely nothing has
a number of properties I want you to see
whether you agree with me but because my
argument depends upon it
I'm going to talk about absolutely
nothing and which I will call nothing
with a capital N or there would be sort
of and I don't want you to think that
it's just empty space time I mean that
would be cheating
this is absolutely nothing at all no
space no time just absolutely nothing so
clear your minds ok and the properties
of nothing as far as I'm concerned is
that it is totally uniform and you can't
have lumps of absolutely nothing more
dense than somewhere else right so now
we'll represent it by a little icon like
that I think absolutely nothing is also
isotropic in the sense that it does if
you think of our point somewhere you go
round it nothing changes ok what I by
which I mean nothing doesn't change
alright so you have to watch them
represent it like that and also by
absolutely nothing I mean that there's
that it's totally empty it's not full of
space
it's not full of time I mean this is a
very Buddhist sort of talk that I'm
giving you but just clear your minds lie
back and think not of England but of
absolutely nothing at all
and I think when the that's my uncle so
this is my image of absolutely nothing
and this is my image of what we've got
more or less now it's showing lacking
some detail of course but I want to
focus on the transition when absolutely
nothing turned into what appears to be
something and talk further about the
role of indolence now there's a hero of
mine and I'm using hero in the feminine
sense sorry I'll come to her in a moment
and one of the laws of nature which i
think is probably the most important of
all the laws of nature so let's get it
out of the way is the conservation of
energy and you are all familiar with
what happens when a ball rises and comes
back down again it might have a lot of
kinetic energy initially for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you